[Music]
gaza's intensive care units are filling
up
this week nearly 90 percent of the icu
beds equipped to treat covert 19
patients
were occupied the mathematics of the
surge in cases
seem inescapable experts warn the system
will soon be overwhelmed
the mortality rate is is getting higher
from march to october there were 50
death cases in two months from october
to
first of december the number has been
doubled
in recent days more than 30 percent of
those being tested have registered
positive for the coronavirus
with two to three thousand tests carried
out a day in a population of two million
it's thought only a fraction of cases
are being detected
gaza's hamas run health ministry is
calling on the population to follow
safety measures
and on the international community for
help
otherwise a dangerous scenario is
waiting for us and we might find
ourselves
forced to take harder preventative
measures in the coming days
including a general lockdown for much of
this year gaza's besieged blockaded
status had helped keep it almost
entirely insulated from the pandemic
but since the detection of community
transmission in august
the other realities of that 13-year
isolation
enforced by israel and egypt the ravaged
economy
the teaching health system are worsening
the crisis
health officials also blame a lack of
public compliance on masks
gatherings and social distancing a
lockdown in late august
hurt an economy where already 65 of
young people
are unemployed those who've clung onto
their jobs
worry about what a second lockdown might
mean
we already get half salary because of
the bad economic situation
and there is fear that the owner of the
business could reduce the working days
and pay us
even less as the new covered 19 measures
destroy the business
and there are security concerns too
after recent weeks in which rocket fire
into israel
and airstrikes on gaza have started to
resume
the three editions of the health social
economic situation in gaza
is posing security threats
do we need to have another war do we
have another to have another
protest on the border international
community need to understand that gaza
cannot
continue like this
recently there has been some increased
assistance 15 ventilators from kuwait
oxygen from qatar but a wave of disease
is already on the way
gaza's shaky institutions are said to be
tested to
and perhaps beyond their limits harry
fawcett
al jazeera